theet is a is a remarkable cinematic
achievement and uh I'm always in love
with movies that are tackling with that
existential Sensation that you're
walking into the unknown uh it happens
with movies that are dealing with time
uh a film like Ley the Chris marker I
suppose that you like oh yeah or movies
like uh it's a sensation that I felt
when I watch 2001 on Space odyc the
first time are watching Inception or
Interstellar it's a it it requires a lot
of discipline and a lot of Mastery to to
be able to achieve that and I'm I'm
curious
about for tenet if you could share with
us where this the idea come from what is
the birth of the idea of this mad idea
of the inverted enthropy I think um the
the kicking off point really was was a
long time ago when when I made um one of
my earlier films momento and um the
beginning of momento has a sequence
that's shown in Reverse
chronology uh because the entire film is
then structured in Reverse chronology
and so I included a a backwards
opening uh you know where a guy Pier
shoots Joe pantalon in reverse and you
know begins with him catching the gun
and and that kind of thing and it's sort
of stuck with me that I'd be interested
in
exploring that reality uh the reality
that the camera can show us that we
can't see um with the first you know the
the movie generation you know this 100
years or so with the first people uh to
ever be able to see time in different
ways it's the movie camera that's shown
us time backwards um it's one of the
original kind of fascinating effects of
what a movie camera can show us and so I
became interested in the idea quite some
time ago uh really following on from
momento of rather than um the structure
of the story being backwards what if you
could literally change the direction of
time for a character or for an object
and and have two directions of time
existing in the same frame so not time
travel not jumping around in time uh but
actually looking at the physical process
of time which is I had dealt with um
a lot in
intercell uh and i' spent a lot of time
talking to Kip Thor great physicist who
uh helped me with tenant as well because
it was so much fun sitting around
talking to him about the implications of
of real world physics and so much of it
is truly Stranger Than Than Fiction when
you're dealing with relativity black
holes you know those kind of things and
we had explored that so much and enjoyed
exploring that together and interstella
as I got into tenet I you know I called
him and I started talking about this and
notion of if you could invert the
entropy of an object or a person um and
some interesting things immediately came
out of it like the idea that uh you
wouldn't be able to breathe air uh
because it wouldn't pass across the
membranes in the same way or eat a
chicken for instance what happen if you
chicken exactly there's a lot of w ifs
that that the film is designed to
inspire yeah but it's this this so the
idea of the uh the to uh roach time uh
with enthropy uh uh came from you and
not Kip uh it it did I'd always been
fascinated by the notion that all the
laws of physics are reversible they're
all symmetrical in time in terms of time
and so there's no reason that the entire
universe can't run backwards except for
one law and that's entropy and there's
um I suppose you'd call it a conflict or
disagreement in in amongst physicists as
to whether that's cause or effect you
know whether entropy is the sign of the
arrow of time or whether it's the cause
of it for the purposes of our film we
view it as the cause of it so we we
postulate okay what if there were a
machine that could you know flip that um
and then the idea to merge that with the
the the a spy movie yeah came
spontaneously or you you you you leave
that idea is living this idea of time
travels lives by itself for a while or
I think for me it was always fused with
at least a thriller scenario I mean
coming from this idea of guy Pearson
momento shooting somebody backwards you
know the kind of kinetics involved in
action Cinema Thrillers um so I think
the Spy genre was always really part of
it for me because it's the genre that
gives you access to all of these uh
wonderful kinetic action movie tropes uh
you know the gunfire fight the car chase
you know armies fighting each other
these kind of things and what I wanted
to do was really explore the sort of
experience of of watching an action film
or watching a uh a spy movie um and sort
of build out from that and try and build
this sort of big screen very immersive
experience you know based on that to try
and sort of take it to another level and
and find a reason for an audience to to
watch a car chase again and watch it in
a different way and try and sort of look
down the other end of the telescope at a
lot of these tropes that we all kind of
know and love from action Cinema yeah
and more specifically from James Bond
because I I felt that you were playing
with the bond is almost a gener in
itself and you have like some egyp one
there you have like the Exotics place
you have the Bond girl you have like the
the the villain with that has always
like and I felt that you were playing
with those those codes and something
having fun and uh in a subversive
subversive way yeah I've always been a
huge fan of of the Bond films as anyone
who's seen any of my movies would would
know but especially this one um or
Inception as well I suppose um I think
there's also a lot of uh the lare
approach to
espionage uh you know and I think partly
that's
because with a Bond film we have James
Bond at the center nobody worries too
much about the reality of the Spy world
that they're in but when you have have
an anonymous figure at the center the
protagonist you know John David
Washington's character um I wanted to
take on some of that uh complexity some
of that sort of jargon based sort of
more John ler more bit more sort of real
world spycraft uh feeling about the
character and the way he interacts do
you do you I heard that uh Spielberg
created the Indiana Jones in reaction
that he he was not allowed to direct a
Bond movie did you direct your own Bond
movie doing T I think I think I think I
did yeah and I think I really got to uh
we go I I got to have a lot of fun with
it um certainly with Inception you look
at the end of inception with the the
sort of ski Chase and the big fortress
in the snow that was very much a sort of
homage to on our Majesty Secret Service
which is my favorite of the bonds I
think um but I think with this yeah I
just went into that mythology fully
because what I was sort of trying to do
was create a style ized science fiction
experience on top of that and so you're
trying to use the same way momento try
to use the familiarity of the tropes of
the film Noir you know tenet as an
attempt to use the audience's
familiarity with the spy movie genre the
Bond movie um to be able to take it
someplace uh a little crazier someplace
a little different and and have us
experience it in a different
way there's something about uh uh
there's a there's a lot of spectacular
scenes in in inet but one of them that
really absolutely blew my mind was this
close combat between the protagonist and
himself and it's probably I don't I
don't say that to uh please you but it's
probably one of the most exciting combat
sequence on fil story seriously it's
it's mind-blowing what you you were able
to achieve on camera and and and I would
love if you could explain to us a little
bit how did you achieve uh uh having uh
uh both uh uh actors uh uh fighting in
different time Direction uh it was not
so much my achievement as my challenge
to an incredible crew George cotle stunt
coordinator Jackson pel fight
coordinator and then John David
Washington who was in the NFL incredible
athlete uh and had such dedication to
learning this very long fight fight from
both sides so he had two versions of the
fight to learn uh protagonist antagonist
and then he had to learn it backwards
for both parts as well and we shot it
day one you know we started with it um
and you know I I just wanted because I I
sort of felt like sometimes it's good to
start with the hardest stuff because we
knew there were so many mindbending
things to work out later in the film I
felt like if every Department you know
if stunts and wardrobe and uh production
design camera you know if everybody
could come together and figure out how
to do that we'd be in better shape for
when we got to the middle of Talon and
shot the whole city down and did a
massive car chase you know we we really
had to know what we were doing by then
and so it was this approach to shooting
um everything in camera there are no you
know visual effects in those fights and
it's all incredible performance and
knowing the fight four different ways um
and being able to switch with it and
then hoyaa shooting on IMX
handheld um according to a rule set that
I put in place that basically said we
weren't ever going to reverse the
footage so we weren't ever going to use
something from that we'd shot for the
first fight sequence we see it for the
second each piece of film is unique and
so everything has changed slightly uh in
order to give you a different
perspective on things and so I mean the
most obvious example for people who've
seen the film more than once may have
noticed is um The Tint you know on the
mask that John David's wearing it's
completely dark the first time you're
seeing that antagonist the second time
you see it it's a lighter tint so that
you can see his eyes through it because
we're seeing it from his perspective so
the camera's closer to him we're seeing
his expressions and and doing that
similarly with the sound we're we're
using you know his sound as foreground
so first as the suited protagonist uh
without the mask and then the second
time we see it we're we're favoring the
sound of the guy behind the mask whose
eyes we can now see a bit but the camera
angles are different and the axis is is
different but it meant that one actor
was doing the choreography backwards and
the other one was going and it's it's
it's just like I'm trying to explain it
to myself Chris I all night I thought
about it last night I one had to do it
forward so John David had to do it
forwards he then had to get change
different costume and do it backwards uh
and needed to know uh sorry I misspoke
there was no wardrobe change you'd do it
backwards in the same wardrobe um
although we had a different tie so it
was stiffer so it wouldn't move the same
way that kind of thing uh and then he
would have to go get changed into the
SWAT outfit to do the entire fight
forwards then do the entire fight
backwards in that wardrobe and then we
took everybody to Estonia to Talon and
we shut down a freeway across the city
and we had to do that the stunt guys had
to do that with cars they had to do it
with driving and literally do a Chase
for forwards with regular Vehicles
forwards and with vehicles that would
drive backwards at speed uh and then the
other way around and so everything was
sort of shot four different ways and uh
they did just an incredible job um
putting together all these rigs to be
able to do that it's it's it's it's it's
it's remarkable the the
the I've seen the movie many times and I
love movies that are like enigmas movies
that the more you revisit them you see
new things every time but you have to
watch them a couple of times and then
it's definitely one of of those and uh I
had uh I went online to see uh how
people dealt with with the with and I
seen remarkable uh uh Graphics where
people were trying to explain and it
looks like a madman Subway you know like
with map and it even then when you look
at it visually uh uh it's it's uh pretty
impressive it's still difficult to
understand my question is as a filmmaker
when you make a regular movie with a
very simple narrative you still have
Sometimes some of your crew member that
are confused were you the only one
keeping the the compass on set
or I've done I've done films where I'm
I'm in that role of of the only person I
think with a lot of inception sometimes
I was the person with a handle on it
with tenner what we found is I had a
handle on I was writing the script but
when it comes to the execution and the
detail uh I didn't have a handle on any
more than anyone else we had to prev
visualize things we had to look at
computer Graphics we had to use tools to
be able to look at the palindrome of
each sequence to look at it one way look
at at the other and work on it from both
ends together so of any of the films
I've done it was the most collaborative
effort you know we would all get in the
room and there were no we we said right
from day one we learned this there are
no stupid questions because what we
found is everybody's
brain you would you'd get certain things
right and you couldn't understand why
other people couldn't get them and then
you'd suddenly realize you were wrong
you know and a lot of it was about
diagrams and rules and and all the rest
so a huge amount of work went into prev
visualization and we would change things
on the previs to make sure that the
sequences all worked you know
completely um so it was a very very
collaborative effort uh it was it was
never
a the the base basic concept behind
tenet with the mixing of of timelines
within the frame it was something that
we realized as we shot you were never
able to Intuit it it's something you
have to experience so you could describe
and even in the edit Suite you know I
was working with Jen lame um and you
know I would try and explain something
to it but ultimately you had to sort of
put it together and then talk about it
look at it and then look at it different
directions and talk about it and that's
what I kind of loved about the concept
it's purely a cinematic conert you know
you you have to sit in the movie theater
and watch it and let it wash over you
and sort of experience it it's not
something you can
intellectualize yeah I understand that
the the I would love uh um if you you
were talking a bit about IMAX earlier
and and uh to talk about uh what is the
percentage of uh IMAX uh in the movie
exactly gosh no but I don't you no no
it's been a few years so but but but
it's it's there let's say not the old
movie no and I was wondering uh oh what
is your decision is it driven by sound
for me a lot of the time it's driven by
by sound um because IMX film cameras are
very noisy they're huge ENC compassive
and very noisy and so you have to make
decisions about whether want you post
synchronize the sound or whether you
want to be able to record and use the
real performances which I always prefer
so the film is a mix of 65mm 5 per which
you can you know pan has a quiet camera
for that uh and that's the letter box
format and then it expands to the 15 per
70 mil usually for the action sequences
and what we found over the years is
there are different cut points you can
mix you know you can put that cut point
in a different place to either make the
screen feel like it's suddenly expanding
um or you can disguise the cuts I mean
in the final sequence when the
protagonist is in the back of the car
all the shots inside the car are letter
box and the ones outside aren't and it
plays because of the low ceiling and the
dark ceiling of the car um so it's
something that from we first started to
play with uh in the dark KN yeah we've
been messing around with it ever since
in different ways yeah because it's it
creates almost it's a new way to install
the uh uh in the use a new we have a new
editing tool in some ways to create
impact and as you rightly said uh uh to
tell you the truth I remember studying
at The Dark Knight and and an
Interstellar the first time I uh for
part one when when when I had to for the
first time shoot in 143 start trying to
uh make my own decisions about I will
approach part one part one of Dune ah
Dune which reminds me
so the five minute piece you saw at the
front uh which is from Dune 2 I just
want to turn the tables CU we're running
out of time and ask you a few questions
about Dune 2 but thought that was F
talking about I know I know
and uh I know spoilers and all the rest
there's not much that you can say about
it at this point but I've seen it so I
can't say whatever I feel like about it
uh being respectful spoilers but uh
watching the piece uh into this format I
was frankly just thrilled how amazing
the translation is to this format for
the film I think it's a incredibly
exciting way for for people to see it
and what I was really struck by was the
sense of immersion in that world world
there's a little bit of we talked about
a little bit of grit to it there's a
little bit of the the emotion of of that
you you feel you know watching that that
scene where um you know Tim is is
reunited uh and reveals himself it's
it's thrilling and very emotional as it
is in the the finnished film um I just
wanted to ask you looking at the minds
the detail of that world and how it
works where does where has that all come
from because without saying too much
about the finished film it's a film that
has so many Unique Images so many things
you've never seen before in this movie
time after time and I was so struck by
the detail of everything those Minds
coming out of the sand and things like
that and they're not all from the book I
mean where where is that coming from
with your team how are you putting those
details together uh frankly it's like U
uh things that I spent a lot of time in
the screenly uh uh I wrote with John
Spade but I I spend a lot of time myself
alone and and and Through the Years
there's ideas that I I accumulated that
I wanted to insert in in this film and
then it's really it was all inspired by
Frank Herbert the book but it's true
that I had to come up with idea to bring
the words in a more cinematic way and
and it's just like a uh a lot of things
are coming out of the storyboard process
as well where I have to Translate scene
and to find the most economic and and
the most exessive exessive way to to to
bring ideas to the screen where it's
almost like an extension of my brain
where I can uh uh uh in the very
intimate moment dream uh that's where a
lot of ideas are coming from visual
ideas are coming from are you a good
drawer are you no not particularly and I
I don't actually storyboard that much
I've done certain sequences I mean it's
fascinating to hear that you so
creatively you started with
storyboarding before you ever got a
camera yeah yeah and the thing is that I
feel still today once the the the
screenplay is done I will storyboard
most the of the movie of if not the
entire movie and it's a new way to
rewrite and to approach bring the words
closer to the to the camera and I then
once the storyboard I finished I rewrite
the screenplay again again from the
storyboards because there's a lot of
changes that will be found through the
story boards uh and it's a way also to
for me to find the alphabet and the
vocabulary that would be used the
Cinematic alphabet of the film The
Rhythm everything is in the boards and
is that before you have the whole team
on or absolutely absolutely I do it by
myself and it's a way to dream about the
movie in the most intimate way it's one
of my favorite moment of the film
process now I there's a a rule on my set
is that uh uh the the storyboard
precedes the the the screenplay and
nature precede the storyboard so which
means that most of the time I throw the
storyboard out and we improvise with the
camera but uh but it it secures me to
find the movie with the boards I think
it's almost a uh a different way to
write to go deeper into the
screenwriting process more specifically
for the Cinematic sequences yeah yeah
yeah so what do you feel comfortable
telling this audience about the new film
what do you what are you comfortable
revealing in this in this environment if
anything but listen uh uh uh first of
all it's like a movie that I've tried to
uh create that would be a standalone
meaning that it's like a direct
of of part one but I wanted the movie to
be able someone who would have not seen
part one will be able to to enjoy part
two uh I gave enough clues in it uh to
to make sure that uh uh someone yeah uh
you don't need to have seen part one I
will say that uh uh I feel it's a much
more I don't know if you agree a more
muscular movie it's a movie that has
more action sequence and as a filmmaker
was much more uh much more challenging
but definitely more had much more fun
doing it because it's like we go it's a
a GE Gia Warfare movie where we follow
Paul and sheny starting to do gas again
the aranan and um I will say for the the
fans of the book the people who know the
book that the movie is slightly
different I can say that when Frank
Herbert wrote the or the first book he
was a bit disappointed of people
perceived uh the book uh because for him
Paul was not a hero he was a dark figure
he was someone it was for it was like
the B book was a cautionary tale about
uh Messianic figures and uh uh to
correct uh uh the perception he wrote
dun Messiah to make sure that people
will understand that so I tried at my
best to do this adaptation closer to the
initial intention of Frank
Herbert well and I I won't uh
necessarily ask your exact point of
reference but for me I don't think it's
say too much to say that you know if
June part one was Star Wars this to me
was very much The Empire Strikes Back
which is my favorite of the Star Wars
films and I just think it's an
incredibly exciting expansion of all the
things you introduced in the first one
uh yeah I I I have to say to you Chris
that there is a massive compliment and
and uh I'm pleased to know that you love
The Empire Strikes Back as well that's
nice that's nice to know I do indeed and
I think that that your your sequel
reminded me of it in all the right ways
whilst being completely different from
it so uh I think it's an extraordinary
piece of work and I think people are
going to be amazingly uh excited to see
it and they'll be able to see it on IMX
film so our tenant re-releases the 23rd
and then June 2 will be on the same
screen also 70 mil film print um and
it's a wonderful translation I think it
the format looks looks incredible there
so I I need to say that I was able to
bring Dune part two I shot it for IMAX
but I was able to do a translation to to
to to we were able to do fil prints
because of you because of the success of
appenheimer and that I'm so grateful
again Chris Nolan I cannot say thank you
enough for what you doing for
Cinema
thank um yeah and on that note I know
it's it's so we should we should wrap it
up but I I actually just want to very
quickly uh acknowledge uh someone who's
in the the credits of uh tenant uh who
worked at Warner Brothers for many years
called Scott null he was one of the best
projectionists at Warner uh who passed
away uh just last week and it made it
just makes me feel better to say his
name to people uh and acknowledge uh all
the great work he did for me over the
years but
also keeping film alive having the these
kind of screenings what we're going to
get to do with tenet what we did with
Oppenheimer this summer and what you're
going to get with June 2 what you're
going to get to do uh totally dependent
on the guys in the booth uh these
incredible projectors who work so hard
for us so I just want to take a minute
to acknowledge them and thank them for
everything they've done for us um and I
want to thank you Denny for for being
here this evening telling us a little
bit about you thanks gr thank thank you